is that not why why is that funny it's
not funny it's absolutely
mental I'm Paul mascal and I'm Andrew
Scott and we're going to be taking a
co-star test we feel very confident
about this building up for this for
years yeah that's what it's all about
[Music]
really the part of Ireland that uh
Andrew is from is South County Dublin
yeah and you're from minut yeah very
specific yeah we're doing well so we're
off to a fly your ticket yeah this this
is great the role they're most proud of
oh wow it's hard I do think it's normal
people still it's it's a tie between
after sun after sun and nor it's a tick
is it a tick I was going to say Hamas
you're right come on yes yes oh this is
good we know this okay their favorite
snack to grab at craft Services
istics the book movie or TV show they're
always recommending oh I know what
you're drag race actually yeah
absolutely what what what's mine well
I'm going to go oh it's book movie or TV
show I was going to say if it was music
but not probably a TV show that I
recommend the most no there's a book
that you recommended to me last year do
you remember can you think ho
Bible oh I've already read that TV show
that you've seen just 3 2 one shoot from
the head 3 two one the 18 team oh the
True Detective so you didn't get that to
me their first celebrity crush who was
the person that you said already Sports
person Billy Jean King Billy Jean King
no Paul I don't know power to Billy Jean
King no what year were you born 96 mine
is wild what what age were you like 14
your first crush was in 2010 is it a
singer yeah jewel no Cheryl Cole oh wow
Cheryl Cole you got to fight for this
love you got to fight for this love yeah
so we both get that the last the last
text oh Jesus you sent a lovely text you
said I'm happy you ignore it yeah sorry
I'm aonic look it's all coming out now
get ghosted I didn't but thank you
BuzzFeed thank you for I'm a bad texter
but I got that right you did get what
was the last text that's the main that's
the main thing as long as you get it
right uh what's the last text you sent
me oh I can't remember so long ago I'm
more of a phone caller that's true
actually yeah it's nice that you do that
zodiac sign I don't know zodiac signs
your birthday recently but I just don't
what the sign I don't I don't know signs
either what is your sign H Libra I'm an
aquarius so we didn't get that okay
their Dream Theater role Hamlet no oh
that could be yours no definitely is it
a Shakespeare no is it oh no wait wait
wait wait wait hold a second well you
just C it on Stanley that can I take
back Hamet because that was one is yours
Shakespeare no it's much more general
what would I like to be to it's a type
of it's just to be or not to be that's
the question yeah that is the question
question buzfeed yours is do you have
one in mine yeah I have one but mine is
specific to now it's a it's a dream roll
for now can we just tell each other cuz
I'm curious now and I'm not going to be
able to guess it I just want to be in a
musical you want which one you need
great Bobby you need and Company no I
need to be in a musical where you don't
need to be able to see that's a problem
mine is B from Death of a Salesman oh
wow yeah what a great great oh maybe I
could be um what's the name of the
girl fa Roman Empire are you the random
thing they're always thinking about like
my dad would think about the Roman
Empire quite a lot would he yeah the
Gladiator Beach
Boys do you think of it is that not why
why is that funny why is that it's not
funny it's
absolutely would you talk to about
liking them a lot today the beach
Bo right not the Beach Boys I'm going to
take that P that never
happened a second
wait said today the Pet Shop Boys Pet
Shop Boys it was the Pet Shop Boys the
peach boys my new Roman Empire is when
we're going to get you into a lunatic
assignment I think we need to say that
we didn't get that right their favorite
way listen to the
beach I would be to drink yeah drink we
love drink we like a drink yeah their
favorite memory from all of us strangers
remember when I played my Beach
Boys C that was my favorite memory oh
was great great memor this is really
hard it is hard cuz I don't even know
what my favorite memory is you know what
one of my favorite memories was was
actually when we were shooting a sex
scene very early one morning and we
acknowledged how hilarious it is to be
yeah crack of dawn exactly gra each
other right away with lots of
people it was literally a Monday morning
it was like welcome to the week too much
too much people don't need to see this
but like in a wasis of just like having
a laugh in the middle of God we both got
those right we did the most Dream song
something by the gloaming that's good
yeah you got that right Pet Shop Boys
you said you said earlier unless you
were lying in the I just think you need
to leave anything with boys I I'll give
him that one yeah yeah you were saying
that earlier go to take out order I'll
get this I have this for you Waka oh my
God Spot On Spot on I can't remember
what the exact order but it's exactly
the same order I know you get all the
same thing exactly the same thing
chicken tacos chicken quesadilla potato
gravas and a can of Coke full fat Coke
full fat Cokey come on taking the out of
that I don't know what your take out
would be come on give it a guess uh do
you like Chinese food no oh okay miss
that one what is your favorite take it's
Pizza how do they take their coffee or
tea come on I think about
this my
breathing I was thinking I was thinking
of of giving you like giving you a hint
but then I told on camera you can see us
drink C I was going to say I don't think
you drink coffee tea tea I don't drink
tea don't I would would have said you
don't drink coffee what do you drink
would you drink a latte M I would if I
had to but you wouldn't want to like a
black coffee no flat white they most
famous person in their contact oh god
well now you're working well now he's
the Gladiator now everybody's in his
contact yeah try to get them out of
there is the
problem famous person in your
contacts
you you are no no no no no uh Pho W
Bridge she's pretty famous pretty famous
yeah you have you can that I can yeah I
have a little tick who do you think is
the most famous person in my contact
Denzel no I don't Denzel my
contact i' would love to have if you're
watching
this give us little
whatspp uh could you imagine
there up shut up talking about Pedro
Pascal yeah yeah yeah you got that good
their favorite project of yours oh how
do we answer this one it's like a double
what you think is what I what what I
think you
think that's a bit narcissistic isn't it
I know what you think is my op I bet you
loved me in everything really tough one
to answer uh basically what we're saying
is I think you thought I was brilliant
in something a you're so good in
everything though isn't he so good
acting does anyone does anyone think
Paul's good at
acting I'm going to
say after s oh it's a different one
you're going to say again it's it's a
tuss but it's normal people that's just
unbelievable get those right Talent of
flip and talented at everything is there
anything a man can't do apart from
remember the names of
bands I'm not I I feel like I don't have
like a like a like playing the banjo or
yeah I don't have any of those things
can you do any of those weird things
like where you click something in no I
can click this there there you go in my
fingers I don't have any hiden talents
you can do a mighty cartwheel
no I don't know we didn't get that
either do you have a hidden T no their
middle name I'm just going to guess this
go on Andrew Andrew moris Michael Scott
oh my God no no there's no hope in hell
oh my no oh my
God he's really good at acting I believe
that it was very good that would be so
ad I think it's something gaic come on
give us a little clue it's not uh is it
Irish e they're both Irish names yeah
but there it's not gay not Patrick no
Sean you can't this isn't the game okay
um Paul um
M Paul M man Paul M man mes oh it's Paul
colum Michael mesco Paul colum Michael
mesco it's a good little um f War up
there a former co-star of theirs that
they love to work with again Daisy 100%
yeah I could just take a pick I could
just be like kie Phoebe uh yeah oh yeah
like all the above yeah give him that we
give him that yeah favorite place to
vacation to go on holidays IA the fancy
part of IA you sort of ask I was only
invited there I'm not I'm too much of a
Scot to
be no but did you not like grease yeah
like a bit of Grease come on give it to
see the way I'm like very generous with
giving it to you and you're like no we
didn't get that one get I
win yours
is say no I shouldn't say but I know
where you like to go no say it no no not
say why would I be embarrassed by where
I like to well I just don't want to like
it's a place that you go where do I go
you've been there that's going to be so
annoying for people if you don't say
this and all those places yeah that I'm
glad you didn't yes yeah thank you yeah
great you got that that's thank you yeah
I'm done I'm done I'm done with
youo who you're pretty good friends with
your co-star oh God is he going to it's
going to say you absolutely devoted 11
out ofat you but you still get the same
you still get we still got the same
reviews we didn't get the same you're
pretty good friends with your co-star
you're pretty good friends with your
co-star it's it's kind of giving a lot
of this energy like yeah yeah right
pretty good not great but I did beat you
by one you did that's true yeah thank
you buz for us and thanks for watching
yeah oh be sure to watch be sure to
watch what we've just oh all of us our
film our film be sure to watch all of us
strangers so be sure to watch what you
just watched yeah be sure to watch all
of us strangers and it's going to be in
in cinemas on December the 22nd in the
states and on January the
26th in the UK and aren't it that was
very good wasn't it yeah
[Music]
yeah